marée noire au maroc il a fallu dix
jours pour que les autorités se rendre
compte de l'ampleur de cette catastrophe
écologique le maroc qu'on appelle à
présent à l'aide internationale
roumanie le nouveau gouvernement définit
ses priorités avant tout sauver
l'économie du pays les roumains se
préparent à leur premier réveillon de
liberté israël a ministre travailliste
démis de ses fonctions on lui reproche
ses contacts avec l'ol paie atmosphère
de crise encore 100 kilos d'explosifs
contre un hôtel at acte politique ou
crapuleux
l'attentât n'a toujours pas été
revendiqué bonsoir
avant de développer tous ces titres un
retour sur les voeux du président la
réplique que vous venez tout juste
d'entendre dans son message de bonne
année aux français le chef de l'état a
donc surtout évoqué les espoirs suscités
en 89 par les diverses révolutions qui
se sont produites à l'est françois
mitterrand
rendant hommage à mickael gros patch of
a expliqué sa vision d'une grande
confédération européenne
une union de tous les états acceptant le
principe du pluralisme jean-louis le
sèche
vous savez rachid l'idée n'est pas
nouvelle mais elle n'avait jamais été
formulées aussi explicitement la grande
confédération européenne à laquelle
aspire françois mitterrand cette
appliqué à 1989
le vieux rêve du général de gaulle
l'europe de l'atlantique à l'oural
mais à cette nouvelle donne politique le
chef de l'état mais un préalable et
quatre conditions le préalable c'est que
la communauté économique actuelle des
douze continue de se renforcer les
conditions c'est que dans les pays de
l'est ou des bastilles sont tombés cette
année le pluralisme devienne réel les
élections soient démocratiques
le système représentatif et
l'information libre cette confédération
n'est peut-être pas pour tout de suite
reconnaît monsieur mitterrand d'autant
qu'il faudra veiller à l'intangibilité
des frontières existantes et aux
conditions dans lesquelles se réunira le
peuple allemand
un slogan sécurité et paix le président
de la république voit dans cette
nouvelle perspective une occasion de
rendre la france plus ouverte et plus
fraternel et les français moins frileux
et - repliés sur eux-mêmes et françois
mitterrand d'en appeler sur les grandes
options au consensus politique et
syndical alors bien sûr ce n'est
peut-être pas pour demain ni même pour
l'année 90 mais à la vitesse où souffle
le vent de l'histoire depuis quelque
temps qui sait
le reste l'actualité véritable
catastrophique écologique catastrophe
écologique pardon large du maroc le
maroc qui a demandé une assistance
internationale pour combattre la marée
noire qui menace son littoral 70 mille
tonnes de pétrole s'approche du rivage
du pétrole qui s'écoule d'un bateau
iranien victime d'une explosion il ya
dix jours visiblement la catastrophe a
été sous-estimée dans un premier temps
patrice pollet à proximité des côtes
marocaines
voici les premières images du crack 5 le
pétrolier iranien de 270 mille tonnes
depuis douze jours des flancs yves
entrée du navire s'échappe
inlassablement 200 tonnes de pétrole
brut à l'heure c'est un incendie et une
explosion qui sont à l'origine de cette
fortune de mer une explosion survenue
seulement à 180 km des côtes marocaines
les 35 membres d'équipage ont
immédiatement abandonné navire pour être
ensuite recueillis par un bâtiment
soviétique
mais depuis cet instant la mer a changé
de couleur pour virer au noir
soixante dix mille tonnes de brut menace
les côtes du maroc
c'est seulement hier que le gouvernement
marocain établi une cellule de crise et
demandé l'aide internationale
le navire a été retenu jusqu'à 20 milles
au large des côtes c'est-à-dire 35
kilomètres l'écho du nord contre sa
fille et djelida et la marée noire les
nobles centre de cette énorme qui marée
noire qui couvre 65 mille hectares déjà
se trouve à peu près 70 km des côtes du
maroc et marches vers l'école
il ya donc une menace grave pour le
maroc mais aussi pour la conscience
universelle
une équipe de spécialistes est envoyée
sur place
elle tentera de colmater les brèches du
bateau d'autre part six avions marocains
ont répandu des produits dispersants sur
la nappe
une nappe à la longueur impressionnante
elle atteint ce soir 27 km
et puis je la prends le gouvernement
marocain a officiellement demandé ce
soir l'aide de la france pour lutter
contre cette marée noire en roumanie la
situation politique évolue très
rapidement le nouveau gouvernement dans
la formation a été annoncée ce soir
s'est engagé à organiser des élections
libres sous le régime du multipartisme
nous y reviendrons dans un instant car
en ce 31 décembre
les roumains se préparerait aussi à
fêter la nouvelle année alors je me
tourne vers stéphane magnier qui se
trouve en ce moment en direct à bucarest
stéphane il est déjà 21h chez vous c'est
dire que vous êtes encore plus prêts que
nous 90's que l'ambiance est vraiment à
la fête ce soir
oui sauf que vous ne voyez pas dans les
rues que nous lisons sont rentrés chez
eux
vous savez que le gouvernement cet après
midi a annoncé qu'il ouvrait l'accès aux
boîtes de nuit et au restaurant réservé
jusqu'à présent aux étrangers et bien
tout cela est ouvert maintenant aux
roumains et pourtant les roumanie vont
pas parce que traditionnellement le 31
décembre c'est une fête familiale l'aris
en touche chez eux on a vu circuler en
fin d'après midi quelques chars quelques
véhicules blindés qui se sont mis en
place à des postes stratégiques les plus
qu'ils sont partis parce que l'on craint
éventuellement quelques attentes un
baroud d'honneur cette nuit des forces
de la securitate mais surtout ce soir
c'est la fête dans les familles et c'est
une fête qui dure toute la nuit on va
revoir demain matin un peu éméché
peut-être avec une petite gueule de bois
les roumains descendre dans la rue
prévient stéphane nous vous retrouvons à
la fin de ce journal avec toutes les
équipes d'antenne 2 pdf qui vous
entourent abus casse
dans l'immédiat revenant sur l'actualité
de cette journée en roumanie cet après
midi donc le chef de la securitate la
police secrète de ceausescu a été arrêté
il s'agit du général julian plate
appréhendé en même temps que trois
autres responsables de la sécurité
d'autres membres de cette milice ont été
arrêtés ces derniers jours
martine laroche-joubert et jean-françois
hoffman ont pu rencontrer quelques-uns
et leur poser des questions dans les
locaux de la police de bucarest un
centre de police ce matin à bucarest
c'est ici maison liberté fraternité
égalité après ici dans cette pièce sont
détenues ce que l'on présente comme des
terroristes
des membres de la securitate et qui ont
été arrêtés les 22 et 23 décembre
visage tuméfié menottes aux poignets
pour la première fois il parle et
présentent leur défense
c'est une erreur
j'étais sur les barricades que le court
central mais si les jeux pour ça ça
m'énerve je n'avais pas de messieurs
jean paul comme ça mais dites moi je
suis mme poulin angel non je suis
revenue des permissions et quand j'ai
entendu les j'appelle à la télévision je
suis venu j'ai lutté avec les autres
responsables et répondu à l'appel
connecté à la télé et à la radio les
notes je suis parti le 22 de gilles
icher avec les soldats devant la radio
je suis innocent j'étais armé a tiré été
arrêté sur place
j'ai emprunté la bande de terre et j'ai
tiré des résultats je suis le cuisinier
de cisco il n'avait pas votre emploi du
temps
jusqu'où mais on vérifie si oui bien sûr
qu'il faisait analyser tous suply c'est
moi qui ai goûté vous avez peur n'aie
pas peur du corps à vérifier mon
identité je suis vérifie que je partais
à la maison
vous paraissent avoir peu de chances de
s'en sortir
le jugement de 270 mille tonnes depuis
douze jours des flancs éventré du navire
s'échappe à la sab le mans 200 tonnes de
pétrole brut à l'heure c'est un incendie
et une explosion qui sont à l'origine de
cette fortune de mer une explosion
survenue seulement à 180 km des côtes
marocaines
les 35 membres d'équipage ont
immédiatement abandonné navire pour être
ensuite recueillis par un bâtiment
soviétique
mais depuis cet instant la mer a changé
de couleur pour virer au noir
soixante dix mille tonnes de brut menace
les côtes du maroc
c'est seulement hier que le gouvernement
marocain établi une cellule de crise et
demandé l'aide internationale
le navire a été est venu jusqu'à 20
milles au large des côtes c'est-à-dire
35 km des côtes du maroc entre sa fille
et jedida et la marée noire les normes
le centre de cet énorme qui marée noire
qui couvre 65 hectares déjà se trouva à
peu près 70 kilomètres l'écho du maroc
et marches vers l'école
il ya donc une menace grave pour le
maroc mais aussi pour la conscience
universelle
une équipe de spécialistes est envoyée
sur place
elle tentera de colmater les brèches du
bateau d'autre part six avions marocains
ont répandu des produits dispersants sur
la nappe
une nappe à la longueur impressionnante
elle atteint ce soir 27 km
et puis je la prends le gouvernement
marocain a officiellement demandé ce
soir l'aide de la france pour lutter
contre cette marée noire en roumanie la
situation politique évolue très
rapidement le nouveau gouvernement dont
la formation a été annoncée ce soir
s'est engagé à organiser des élections
libres sous le régime du multipartisme
nous y reviendrons dans un instant car
en ce 31 décembre
les roumains se préparerait aussi à
fêter la nouvelle année alors je me
tourne vers stéphane magnier qui se
trouve en ce moment en direct à bucarest
stéphane il est déjà 21h chez vous c'est
dire que vous êtes encore plus prêts que
nous 90's que l'ambiance est vraiment à
la fête ce soir
oui sauf que vous ne la voyez pas dans
les rues où les gens sont rentrés chez
eux vous avec le gouvernement cet après
midi a annoncé qu'il ouvrait l'accès aux
boîtes de nuit et au restaurant réservé
jusqu'à présent aux étrangers et bien
tout cela est ouvert maintenant aux
mains et pendant les roumanie vont pas
parce que traditionnellement le 31
décembre c'est une fête familiale alors
ils sont tous chez eux on a vu circuler
en fin d'après midi quelques chars
quelques véhicules blindés qui se sont
mis en place à des postes stratégiques
depuis qu'ils sont partis parce que l'on
craint éventuellement quelques attentats
un baroud d'honneur cette nuit des
forces de la securitate mais surtout ce
soir c'est la fête dans les familles et
il c'est une fête qui dure toute la nuit
on va revoir demain matin un peu éméché
peut être avec une petite gueule de bois
les roumains à descendre dans la rue
très bien stéphane nous vous retrouvons
à la fin de ce journal avec toutes les
équipes d'antenne 2 et tdf qui vous
entourent à bucarest dans l'immédiat
revenant sur l'actualité de cette
journée en roumanie cet après midi
le chef de la securitate la police
secrète de ceausescu a été arrêté il
s'agit du général julian vlad appréhendé
en même temps que trois autres
responsables de la sécurité
d'autres membres de cette milice ont été
arrêtés ces derniers jours
martine laroche joubert et jean-françois
hoffman ont pu rencontrer quelques-uns
et leur poser des questions dans les
locaux de la police de bucarest un
centre de police ce matin
à bucarets ici maison liberté fraternité
égalité
bon après ici dans cette pièce sont
détenues ce que l'on présente comme des
terroristes
des membres de la securitate et qui ont
été arrêtés les 22 et 23 décembre
visage tuméfié menottes aux poignets
pour la première fois il parle et
présentent leur défense j'étais sur les
barricades au comité central
c'est pour ça que je retrouve un veinard
je n'avais pas messieurs moi je suis mme
boulet je suis revenue de permission et
quand j'ai entendu des j'appelle à la
télévision je suis venu j'ai lutté avec
les autres j'ai répondu à l'appel
on a vu à la télé à la radio les notes
sur six parties le van gogh et du chai
avec les soldats devant la radio cela je
suis innocent j'étais armé avec mes
genoux retirer j'ai été arrêté sur place
moi je suis le cuisinier de ceausescu il
n'avait pas d'être en pose deux
questions jusqu'où mais oui bien sûr
qu'il faisait analyser tous ces plats y
c'est moi qui l'a goûté les verts sait
pas faire vérifier mon identité je suis
vérifie que
je vais partir en maison pour le moment
car identité il vous paraissent avoir
peu de chances de s'en sortir
le jugement interviendra avant les
élections d'avril prochain
la composition du gouvernement roumain a
été dit fais dit définitivement a lancé
ce soir à bucarest ce gouvernement
composé de 23 ministre travaillera sous
la coupe du comité du front de salut
national
le nouveau régime roumain a officialisé
le multipartisme pour la préparation des
élections d'avril prochain
mais dans l'immédiat la priorité est de
remettre sur pied l'économie du pays
thierry calmette table de conférence et
plantes vertes costume gris et cravate
la première réunion officielle du front
du salut national
les mêmes que nous avions vu dans le
studio 4 de la télévision il se
présentait alors fatigué mal rasé peu
assurée ils ont bien changé aujourd'hui
ces hommes exercent le pouvoir et yonne
il y ait ce coup le précise le conseil
peut désormais annuler les décisions du
gouvernement
si elles sont jugées contraires aux
intérêts du pays autre décision capitale
un décret instituant le multipartisme
dans la roumanie nouvel ep très bowman
le jeune premier ministre souhaite dans
un entretien au journal communiste la
vérité que les nouveaux responsables
soit je cite sans tache entendait qu'il
n'ait pas été compromis dans le régime
du conte du castor défunt mais qui
possède assesseurs une réputation sans
tache dans l'appareil d'état roumain ce
qui amène le conseil du front à devoir
s'appuyer pour gouverner sur des
structures périmés et ajoute le premier
ministre
nous n'avons pas d'autre pour le moment
il leur reste quatre mois avant les
élections libres pour inventer une autre
structure la démocratie en urss la
police a ouvert le feu sur des
manifestants dans la république
d'azerbaïdjan et manifestants qui
réclamaient la démission du responsable
local du parti communiste la police n'a
pas hésité à tirer dans la foule un
jeune homme de 19 ans a été tué 162
personnes ont été blessées situation de
crise politique en israël après la
démission forcée du ministre de la
science ministre travailliste monsieur
weidmann s'est vu reprocher ses contacts
avec l'ol paie ce qui est toujours
interdite par la loi israélienne ses
collègues travaillistes réclame des
explications il n'exclut pas de quitter
le gouvernement de monsieur shamir
charles enderlin
18h d'une émission spéciale de la
télévision y serait dit le premier
ministre itzhak shamir s'adresse au pays
il explique je n'avais pas d'autre choix
que de limoger ezer weizman
il maintenait des contacts secrets avec
l'ennemi avec l'ol paie qu'il
conseillait même et c'est presque une
accusation de trahison que formulent
monsieur shamir qui toutefois n'a pas
voulu révéler ses sources
réservez semaine confirme qu'il a bien
rencontré le représentant de l'ol péage
n'est pas donné de détails sur ces
entretiens et ripostent en traitant ses
collègues au gouvernement d' hypocrite
de toute manière des tilles un négociant
avec l'ol paie par l'intermédiaire des
américains et des égyptiens
c'est la crise le parti travailliste
auquel appartient monsieur weidmann ne
peut accepter son limogeage et menace de
faire tomber le gouvernement
shimon peres le chef travailliste
annonce qu'il n'y aura pas de compromis
que monsieur shamir doit revenir sur sa
décision ou en supporter les
conséquences
c'est à dire que peut-être des élections
anticipées mais la grande question que
l'on se pose ce soir à jérusalem c'est
pourquoi le premier ministre shamir at
il déclenché cette crise maintenant
selon certaines sources
parce qu'ils seraient de plus en plus
inquiète de l'ampleur que prennent les
contacts entre des israëliens et l'ol
fait pour le likoud la droite la
manifestation d'hier à jérusalem est est
significative
tous les leaders palestiniens partisans
de l'ol paie ont manifesté aux côtés des
israéliens du mouvement la paix
maintenant accusé donc d'être complice
de yasser arafat la gauche riposte en
affirmant que les violences policières
étaient destinées à empêcher le dialogue
à tout prix au panama fermeture de
l'aéroport international par les
américains les etats-unis ont annoncé
cette décision prise pour une durée
indéfinie
les reports sert actuellement de base
d'opérations à des unités militaires
américains par ailleurs selon certaines
informations le sort du général noriega
pourrait être réglé dans les prochaines
heures les négociations entre les les
états unis et les autorités
ecclésiastiques semble sur le point
d'aboutir pour sortir l'ancien dictateur
de gré ou de force de l'ambassade du
vatican où il s'est réfugié il y a une
semaine aux philippines toujours pas de
nouvelles du missionnaire français
enlevés
en compagnie de sa nièce aucune demande
de rançon n'a été reçue ce prêtre
français kidnappés par des inconnus
armés avait déjà été enlevée une
première fois en février 85 par des
rebelles musulmans qu'il avait tenu
pendant un mois encore toujours pas de
revendications après l'attentât qui a
entièrement détruit un hôtel la nuit
dernière à sagone la thèse de l'acte
politique semble s'éloigner au profit de
celle d'un règlement de comptes
malgré tout pour l'instant les gendarmes
refusent de privilégier une piste plutôt
qu'une autre
j'en paie cieux cette masse de gravats
c'est tout ce qui reste du hip hop sous
un hôtel de 22 chambres à s'adonner au
nord d'ajaccio
il faut dire que les auteurs de
l'attentât n'ont pas lésiné sur les
moyens
cent kilos d'explosifs reliés à la cuve
de gaz de l'établissement pas de victime
à déplorer
l'hôtel est fermée en cette saison et il
est situé près de la mer dans une zone
peu fréquentée l'hiver personne n'a
revendiqué l'attentât pourtant l'hôtel
qui abritait des gardes mobiles en 87
avait fait l'objet de plusieurs menaces
il ya quatre ans son gérant l'un des
responsables du mouvement corse
française et républicaine
opposés aux indépendantistes été tué à
coups de revolver
et puis cet été autre avertissement
sanglant le fils du nouveau gérant jean
renoir est abattu par un inconnu
ces deux meurtres n'ont jamais été
revendiqués les menaces en tous cas
avait commencé à porter leurs fruits
puisque le propriétaire de l'hôtel un
continental venait de le mettre en vente
alors raquette ou acte politique les
enquêteurs hésitent
certains pensent à une vengeance
personnelle mais la plupart y voient la
main de l'ex flnc qui hier annonçait la
reprise des attentats notamment contre
certaines implantations touristique
encore ce retour à l'actualité à l'est
berlin se prépare à une nuit de la saint
sylvestre est chaude des milliers
d'allemands de l'est et de l'ouest ont
décidé de célébrer la fin de l'année
ensemble plusieurs postes frontières
seront exceptionnellement ouverts
ambiance de fête à berlin corinne
pertuis
le long de la frontière interallemande
en ce dernier week-end de l'année
de longues files d'attentes se sont
formées mercedes mais les autres à ben
est allemande depuis le 24 décembre le
passage est totalement libre plus besoin
de visa ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre
des nouveaux postes frontières ont même
été ouvert spécialement pour la période
des fêtes
c'est dans le sens rda et rfa que les
visiteurs sont le plus nombreux
destination favorite berlin qui retrouve
peu à peu son rôle de métropole
européenne
demain 1er janvier 1990 des milliers de
coureurs passeront sous la porte de
brandebourg d'ouest en est
démontrant une fois de plus s'il en
était besoin que berlin après 25 ans a
retrouvé son unité à bucarest la fête
sera certainement moins gai qu'à berlin
les morts de la révolution sont encore
si proche et l'avenir reste incertain
malgré tout voici une histoire qui
prouve que l'espoir est plus fort en
roumanie
l'histoire de constanta et félicie un
jeune couple qui s'est marié aujourd'hui
à bucarest dans des circonstances très
particulières reportage patricia cost
france brice elle se prépare à la noce
dans le grand musée d'art de bucarest du
champagne des fleurs et des coups de
marteau au réparer on se marie à
l'endroit même place de la république où
a été perpétré un carnage
il y a huit jours une histoire où tout
se mélange dans la tête des mariés
constantin
en terme d'affichage
deux volontaires qui n'ont pas quitté
leur poste depuis l'arrivée de la
surface lors comment un des soldats qui
sont venus aider leur histoire est
exemplaire
il devait se marier ce jour là mais la
situation n'étant toujours pas
normalisées dans luz et ils ont décidé
de faire venir le pop sur plan
madame le même lieu
et
mais sur les autres et dont les
sanctions suis à fleur de peau du kamele
n'goni morts les mariés de l'an ii
l'après ceausescu vont se faire coiffer
de la couronne qui dans la religion de
nox qui symbolise l'avènement d'un
nouvel homme et d'une nouvelle femme
les mariés du musée qui n'ont pas eu le
temps de retourner chez eux ce
changement sont habités par une étrange
tourmente où la joie le disputer
l'espoir à la peur est d'amener dont une
aisée aux noces ou modérée chez gaultier
il me fait
et d'un polo noir et la mère de la
mariée a l'air de ne plus comprendre ses
enfants embarqués en ce début d'année 90
la reine à venir je n'ose pas vous faire
croire radieux depuis dix jours
maintenant antenne 2 s'est efforcé de
vous informer au mieux des événements
qui se déroulent en roumanie plusieurs
de nos équipes sont sur place en
compagnie des techniciens de
télédiffusion de france et grâce à eux
nous avons été les premiers à vous faire
vivre en direct la révolution de
bucarest
grâce à ce que vous allez découvrir sur
cette image tous vont en effet passer le
réveillon loin de leurs familles et nous
voulions donc le rendre un petit hommage
alors ce n'est pas nouveau on vous
connaît pas ce qu'on vous voit souvent
en ce moment mais qui est autour de vous
a causé déjà je suis très heureux qu'on
puisse les voir parce que c'est vrai
qu'ils ont abattu un travail formidable
et puis vous savez quand on parle de
transmission par satellite on pense
justement satellite ordinateur et on
oublie toujours que finalement ça n'est
qu'un stylo et que c'est un homme qui
est derrière quelqu'un la main et en
l'occurrence un stylo électronique de
vidéos c'est plusieurs hommes se sont
toute une équipe des techniciens qui
appartiennent à deux entreprises qui
sont aidées f d'un côté antennes de
l'autre et qui sont coordonnés par
bernard cros qui est à mes côtés et qui
va nous expliquer en quoi cette
opération est tout à fait exceptionnel
oui tout à fait c'est la première fois
que nous sommes venus sous les balles en
direct nous avons parcouru 400
kilomètres en camion avec patrick pons
changer de production et daniel baudin
son collègue qui est derrière et c'est
l'équipe de la vidéo mobile hf2
d'antenne 2 8 techniciens du matin
jusqu'au soir
nous avons ensuite des images en direct
grâce aussi à nos camarades de tdf une
antenne satellite et deux satellites
pour nous relayer nos images en
permanence sur paris la hausse s'avère
plus que c'est d'autant plus
exceptionnelle que ce système a été
repris par énormément d'autres
télévisions étrangères combien bernard
six télévisions étrangères utiliser nos
moyens en permanence pratiquement tous
les jours et grâce à ce système nous
avons fait deux directs vers tokyo est
un ver l'on voit là alors ça c'est
évidemment la partie technique je peux
pas sollicité que les hommes qui sont là
parce qu'évidemment la liste serait trop
fastidieuse mais évidemment sur le
terrain nous sommes tous devenus les
amis et puis il ya les autres il y à
l'ambassade de france en particulier qui
nous a beaucoup aidés il ya vincent
vincent qui est à côté de lui sur
l'ambassadeur qui casse un bras en
écharpe le derrière un manteau qui est
une balle qui l'a atteint au bras alors
qu'il accompagnait une de nos équipes
et puis il ya ceux dont vous entendez
les noms
et que vous ne voyez jamais qui sont les
techniciens ou qui sont les cameramans
jean-françois hoffman jacqueline la
monteuse bruno gex qui se cache un peu
derrière
luciani vous avez roger motte vous avez
françoise joly que vous avez vues
animées également toutes ses envies une
partie de ces transmission directe
je crois que tous nous tous n'ont qu'un
souhait soir un seul un tout petit week
end en même temps un formidable espoir
si nous avons un voeux de bonne année a
souhaité à quelqu'un je crois que c'est
à la roumanie et à tout le peuple
roumain dans lequel nous sommes avec
lequel nous sommes depuis une dizaine de
jumeaux bien si stéphane et sachez que
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 donné
également ce soir à vous souhaiter à
vous tous une très bonne année un bon
retour dans les prochains jours à mon
tour maintenant de vous souhaiter une
bonne année 90 au nom de toute la
rédaction d'antenne 2 une année que
j'espère tout simplement plein de
bonheur ne seront toujours là l'année
prochaine pour vous informer et
d'ailleurs dès demain matin à partir de
6h30 la vaillante équipe de télé matin
sera au rendez vous pour commencer 90 à
votre compagnie bonne soirée
bonne année